I just don't think that we should sleep
on Brock Purdy no more yes he was a
seventh round Pig yes he came in late in
a season and won six straight Games took
him to the NFC championship before his
injury Purdy you would not be slept on
no more brother yes you are surrounded
by a great team but you were playing
your butt off you got one hell of a
story brother I think Purdy's the top 15
quarterback there's things that we still
want to see from Purdy not when Purdy's
winning but when Purdy's down you know I
think diversity aspect of the football
game is huge learning how to play from
behind learning situational football
it's not something I'm saying he can't
do it's just something that we just
haven't seen yet